the 4th of January 2012 it went viral I
sold 16 properties to several investors
you were like making a lot of money but
now you're also becoming very well known
had a massive success and then it all
came tumbling down right
you kind of um got attacked online quite
viciously
so Vanessa worry gosh she wants to
destroy him alive for me you've got
business and then you've got personal
but when someone crosses that line I
find absolutely disgusting you we're
going for a nasty divorce you felt that
Vanessa from property tribes jumped on
it tormented years in 2015 there's 100
000 comment all of social media at that
time my repetition was in tatters
fell apart I actually confronted it I'm
like what is your problem after
basically rising and then falling to the
bottom almost to the pit of Hell what
happened
um
[Applause]
[Music]
Steve Mason respect for you and your
life and what you've done you built up a
pretty big property portfolio had a
massive success and then it all came
tumbling down right yeah correct and now
you've built back up building back up
yeah it's uh starting to turn around
turn the big corner see when I was 21
years old obviously I decided to be a
Plumbing Heating engineer I started in
college in September uh 2001 and
obviously life was quite good at the
care College course
uh day release to through Plumbing uh I
then had a serious Road accident in
December 20 2001. and
um that put me in hospital for uh five
and a half weeks over the Christmas
period
I brought my leg hip pelvis jaw in three
places at metal plates I was
resuscitated three times nine and a half
days in a coma
I had to learn how to walk again I
basically got told I'd never work again
my life was pretty much over that's what
the doctors predicted and my opinion was
um we'll see about that I tried to go
back to work doing a deer release on the
college course it's impossible but I had
a bucket load of experience because I
was just basically self-employed on the
sites by that point fit in bathroom
Suites boilers Etc so I decided to start
my own business I grew that myself and I
ended up employing 35 people in total 34
Tradesmen and one office staff we won a
number of contracts in 2006 onwards into
millions so I think maternal was about
four and a half million pounds
um and that enabled me to buy further
properties I bought like four student
properties prior from 2004 to 2007 in
the uland Avenue area in Hull uh
renovated them so I was just buying like
quite a number of distressed properties
and I was buying properties in at like
50 to 60p in the pound of market value
and then obviously adding value by doing
renovations to them obviously had my
team there which go around and renovate
properties obviously by 2007 the
business was very successful I was like
obviously main contractor for
um several leading Moss Adjusters in the
UK then fourth of January 2012 I walked
into four networking it's gold and I
said I had a presentation to give I and
I thought I'd do about property so like
basically I said I buy a house for 50 or
60 000 I renovate it it's worth a
hundred thousand that's the students in
it and it went absolutely viral I was
like oh my God I remember this at the
time because I was also part of four
networking yeah and I used to deliver
presentations app for networking your
brand is important so you started
growing your Brands and uh what happened
so 4th of January 2012 it went viral I
sold 16 properties to several investors
uh by June I charge them all the
sourcing fee and also bought some more
property but then obviously I got an
opportunity of the High Street shop to
making this into an investment company
estate agency but I was actually doing
very well because I had these 16
properties are sold I've got all the
renovation wet to them so it gave me a
good income so that I could pay the
bills off I could obviously get all my
properties up to scratch I could get
obviously the shop up to scratch and
started my own Investment Company I'm
talking earlier about how if you're
going to hit the rocks at least be a
lighthouse to other people and you kind
of um got attacked online quite
viciously you were targeted what
happened I split from the mother of my
children 2012. uh beginner 2013-ish
obviously stayed friends with her and
then she decided that she want me back
but I didn't want her right and that was
it because I ended the relationship I
couldn't cope like that we got to the
end of 2014 and she accused me of
several things uh so I couldn't see my
children she decided to make all these
accusations public online right because
she knew that was very popular on
Facebook like Facebook was my route to
Market at the time so she contacted
absolutely everybody that I was working
with
um all the people on social media on the
Facebook groups she then make
accusations and because there's that
much rather like competition between the
groups the people as part of UK property
Traders so we had like the HMO group
they got all this information and was
just targeting me uh left right and
center and UK property Traders threw me
out saying we can't have this noise not
done anything wrong and I can prove it
by legal letters and documents and court
orders and everything so Vanessa Warwick
like for me you've got business and then
you've got personal life now she
targeted both areas of my life right so
basically what happened 2015 because
it's happened twice it happened 2015
2018. right she actually got all of my
ex lettings manager who decided to
slander me to all my landlords so I
obviously had all these letters of
landlords getting sent to family courts
you know I mean like landlords getting
involved with family cars and this is
just all about what's going on in your
personal life
that's terrible these guys owed me a
substantial amount of money they're
doing building weight for them one of
them owes me about 26 27 000 pounds that
they haven't paid they saw a great
opportunity not to pay it didn't they
they I mean let's Crush Steve yeah I
mean because you were going through
personal problems apparently I ripped
the children's mum's mum off 80 000
pounds you know I mean there's a clear
loan document I clearly tried to pay it
back you were going for a nasty divorce
and Vanessa was never married okay and
you felt that Vanessa from property
tribes jumped on it oh yeah she
tormented you now
I've never got involved in anybody's
personal life and people come to me
to me I don't care what's going on with
your personal life it's nothing to do
with me I took full custody of my
children in March 2018 16th of March
like she wasn't allowed to see them
literally on the Friday afternoon in
court the judge went to the children's
Mother you are staying here and Mr
Mason's going to collect your children
then there's all these other snowflakes
as I call them getting involved in that
two little kids I found absolutely
disgusting when someone crosses that
line because that's what Vanessa has
done like she crossed that line I
actually confronted her she still
wouldn't reason at all I'm like what is
your problem do I mean don't actually
want to know the truth like no no no no
they actually want want to use that as a
weapon they don't want the resolve which
I find absolutely disgusting so like
obviously 2015 there's a hundred
thousand comments or posts whatever
there was all of social media at that
time my reputation was in tatters I've
say all they love the local agents took
over what business I had so this thing
went on years and years and years just
as a weapon let's destroy this man let's
take everything away from him that is
where it's so hard yeah I mean I've got
a family to support the business is the
business the I mean but where the hair
comes from is that actually affecting
two children that have been emotionally
and physically harmed by their mother
motivation because I was I was very
popular on UK property Traders yeah like
and obviously the associates of that she
doesn't like some of them obviously
there's history with other group admins
that she didn't like uh she thought well
I've got some doubt on Steve like so
what happened the my ex-leans manager
and the Mover of my children
got in touch with a landlord that wasn't
my landlord I'd met him once I said do
not want any business to do with you
leave me alone you're a slum landlord
but then one of the tenants which I
thought at the time was the tenant but
it turns out that he was actually
messaging the mother of my children he
then decided to make a report to the
property ombudsman
all right which man he's not a
tenant they're not allowance nothing to
do with me probably almost someone said
because it's by association you know
them I'm like I thought
I said I do not know these people I've
got no management agreement I've got
nothing leave me alone oh no we're
finding it for this I thought that's
very strange like very strange
I refuse to pay the fine because like I
was just like I've done nothing wrong I
I've got morals at the end of the day if
a new decade have done something wrong
said something bad like I didn't say
nothing she this letting manager ran
away you know what I mean turns out she
ran away with the children's Mother
right
to then obviously Vanessa was contacting
the children's Mother contacting this
license manager of contacting this
tenant and it was a setup basically a
setup didn't matter about the money to
me it's about the principle of it did
you confront Vanessa about that at the
time I did yeah what did she say she
just was so defensive about it saying
like back in every excuse not my fault
not my fault I've got the messages that
you've sent the children's mother who do
you think what yeah I mean yeah like
business business but that's taking it
personal I said there's a good reason
why I've refused to pay that money so
Vanessa was all part of that it was
about 80 grand it's about this this
tenant right like and it was a setup
tenant anyway self-tenant and I had the
80 grand to peer back to the drums
mother's mother yeah I mean but they
refused if someone's actually done
something wrong and it can be proven
right people should know about it right
so if you can category prove that that
person has done something wrong and
they've gone bankrupt they've got a
court order and been locked up for it
people get to know about it because it's
in the news yeah I mean gossip is actual
hard factual evidence right that's what
I work on I don't work on here say or
gossip judging by what she's done
to me and then to every other person
that had a glint of a little bit of Hope
of being successful influencer on social
media she's actually individually
targeted them he actually found a group
of several individuals one with Vanessa
in that was targeting people directly on
social media that was up and coming this
little group will go and find date on
them to Dent that publicly put on
property tribes and on social media and
sending messages out to people she she
plays smoke and mirrors how much of it
do you think could be jealousy because
when someone's being successful if
you've not had that level of success I
mean I know Vanessa hasn't bought a
property since 2009 really so
see you know seeing people smashing it
in property really succeeding getting a
lot of attention do you think could be
maybe jealousy or I don't know what a
problem is why she does it is she
lacking something in life who knows yeah
I mean they up to
what what trauma has she gone through to
be able to end up envious of everybody
do I mean is she lacking something who
knows is something wrong with a personal
life business life if she's not
successful that's what she aspired to be
in the first place so she tries and
texts The credibility of everybody else
the accusations about you that have been
said on property tribes and on Facebook
group went to court you were found
innocent but not none of the defamation
none of the arrest no no but the the
stuff about you being a thief
so what happened then at that point when
she decided no enough's enough I'm going
to get back into business after
basically rising and then falling to the
bottom almost to the pit of Hell I
thought enough's enough let's just
relocate so obviously I moved to London
um best thing that I ever did
um reset my life and because it's about
me being happy
yeah I mean one thing about it is about
me being happy no one's got the right to
take that happiness away like oh no
tough it's my dream I won't be happy I'm
entitled to be happy do I mean not got
ego with that I'm entitled to be happy
everybody is they're entitled to live
quite a peaceful life and also be
successful but I realized being
successful comes with a lot a lot of
issues potentially but them issues can
also be
opportunities you know what I mean no
it's uh I don't see problems with
problems that's like a swear word to me
now a season of opportunity yeah I mean
something comes in yep okay I messed
that up but I fixed that yeah that's
going well what's what's gone wrong
there I've learned something I fix it we
move on to next now we're always
learning yeah I mean business is
business like it's not simple they're in
need a lot of experience like you've got
to learn somehow like but as long as
you've got a good intent you know what I
mean and to do good for others and to
good for yourself and if if you've got a
cool Customer Care customer service so
someone's got a problem okay what is it
how can I help yeah I mean and you've
been acquiring a lot of properties
recently yeah yeah yeah I've acquired
quite a few units lately yeah like
obviously putting the master plan
together
um and you're quite humble as well
because you've like you've just acquired
a whole apartment block is that correct
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um on an option agreement yeah respect
for that brother I mean bringing in good
money yeah like over half a million
pound a year so I just keep very quiet I
don't tell much people about my business
for a good reason
um
but no one will ever stop me I relocated
to London obviously 12 months ago
just over 12 months ago I've seen that
time explored different business
opportunities I think from this October
21 to March 22 I set up a PLC company
but that obviously had a valuation DC
DCF valuation of 71.6 million
I did a lot of heavy networking in
central London met quite a lot of people
that are quite influential in the
investment sector obviously met the love
of my life got married well you got
married that's amazing
ironically wealth is in the Maldives I
met a guy he's uh Diplomat in a very
wealthy country
introduced me to a seller of a Maldives
island which we're exploring on a
purchase option to be able to sell all
the units and acquired a freehold wow
that's the ultimate rise again you
dominate in London as well you've got a
lot of things going on you've got a lot
of stuff going on in London so I've
still got all these sites that are
pulled in and the finance which I'm
exploring still obviously doing deals in
the hundreds of millions the app and
overnight the 18 months to two and a
half years so you're thinking big now
I'm thinking big yeah because the same
amount of work goes into it
but the rewards a lot bigger because one
thing about me all this stuff that's
happened it's made me a little bit um
like hard and emotionally yeah like and
like it's made me realize about being
the best version of yourself and being
number one everything that happens is an
opportunity it's not a problem it's not
negative the positives out absolutely
everything that goes on and learn from
it and actually move forward with it and
use it as a fuel so the the happiness
overrides the pain well I think your
story will inspire a lot of people I
think it's a powerful story it's great
to see you winning again are you happy
now
I'm a happy yeah yeah
I obviously I'm always happy where I am
in life yeah I mean like because the
past is the past and the present is a
gift that's why it's called present and
the future is not written yet I write my
own future you know as I write it out
and say this is what I'm going to
achieve and achieve it it doesn't matter
who's going blah blah blah blah blah
station plus that appreciate you coming
up
[Music]